unless you are something weird eh
yesss
it's said I'd be pro poetin then
but I'm not a pro poet at all
i like poetin 1
dangerous guy
and uh I don't trust a meter
just like me by the way
don't trust all those world leaders
because you only get there if you
in every possible way
with have played false mean games
all I SAY is
Russia exists and it is there
and we are now in the process of ending up 1 war
it wouldn't have been necessary at all
and that alone is seen as 1 extreme
Proputin position while
I think
I am the first to
to recognize that Russia is one very dangerous country
and that that man is 1 very dangerous dictator
and that we absolutely
shouldn't be naive about it
but precisely for that reason
we should not end up in 1 war with him
yes I SAY too
everyone is wrong in this story
there is simply none
good guy there is
it's just not there
because you just see us in the west then
when you watch the gulf war
if you look at Do you still want to sleep
if you look at Libya Libya
Afghanistan Afghanistan mean
you can't say that anymore
that we are on the right track when we like you
if you want to talk about us
because I always think
what do we have to do with that
just so
say it is also that is again
it is fear and it is also something of 1 generation
the people from above
the 50 or something
they were brought up with that cold war thinking
and that is so deep in it that the
east against west Russia
and now that all those fears that are triggered
and those are also things that are
those are almost like boring on like psychological
reflexes that is trained
and that gets triggered and then
then everyone will stand at attention
that is very scary actually how it works
the psychological warfare where we just
I just understand things from the past much better
well yes
I HAVE I studied history in the past and
when I was a student
and I
i just remember
still that I looked at all kinds of processes
witch hunts in the Middle Ages or
I know what French Revolution
or of course the second world war or all those things
and that I thought well but that is
what were those people different in the past
what what what
how do you do your hair with that
and now I think
nope
I just had 1
I had 1 very naive and also 1 bit arrogant
picture of our own time
yes we are no better or worse than
people from the past
it just is
same old story
and we are the freethinkers
that you have had in all times
and which is very special
progress and things have created
but also a lot of persecution and misery
got over them
and that's just
the history that keeps repeating itself